em
2011 o governador eleito do Rio Grande
do Sul me fez um convite para assumir a
cozinha do Palácio Piratini
naquele momento a minha principal
trabalho era na psicologia e e eu tinha
algum trabalho na gastronomia mas muito
secundário
pensei então que eu não deveria aceitar
esse convite Porque na minha imaginação
a cozinha do Palácio talvez fosse a
cozinha a mais simbólica importante do
Estado do Rio Grande do Sul que eu não
estaria altura de assumir uma cozinha
com tamanho a representação e grandeza é
mais pensei de ir até o palácio então e
poder explicar toda essa situação me
chegando lá me deparei com alguma coisa
que me tocou e achei que pudesse talvez
propor um outro trabalho diferente do
que me foi inicialmente sugerido a
cozinha do Palácio Piratini naquela
época fazia 90 anos e até então sempre
serviu ao Governador e os seus
familiares Mas me foi comunicado que era
uma cozinha que naquele momento passaria
a ter apenas à venda de trabalho do
Governador Olá neste diálogo então eu
propus a ele que a gente pudesse talvez
fazer um trabalho de transformar a
cozinha do Palácio de uma cozinha de
recuperação de valorização e de mostra
da culinária do Rio Grande do Sul e da
valorização dos produtos do Rio Grande
do Sul o trabalho que tivesse como base
um trabalho de cunho cultural e também
de valorização da nossa produção
principalmente da nossa pequena produção
foi me dado então sinal verde para
construir esse projeto eu voltei uma
semana no palácio uma primeira escrita
sobre esse trabalho e essa primeira
escrita ela partir dessa ideia da comida
como bem cultural da comida como cultura
e então propus
reorganizar toda uma sistemática até
então dentro do Palácio primeiro que a
cozinha até aquele momento é uma cozinha
coordenada pela casa militar em função
das questões de segurança do Governador
o olhar então eu marco civil passei a
coordenar uma cozinha com 90 anos de
história e principalmente com essas
características de ser coordenado pela
área militar do governo
assumir Então nesse desafio e
organizamos todo o trabalho e eu Desde o
Primeiro Momento
assumiu uma equipe que não existia de
quê organizar uma equipe de dizer o
seguinte aqui no palácio as pessoas
devem chegar para comer aquilo que é
nosso nós não estamos aqui para fazer um
trabalho desde que alguém compare o que
se come no palácio que se comi nos
restaurantes O que é feito pelos grande
chefe Aqui as pessoas devem chegar para
comer aquilo que está na memória das
nossas famílias na memória das nossas
comunidades e poder entender que aqui tá
servido aqui são os nossos produtos
frutos da nossa terra da nossa gente nos
nossos produtos e seu trabalho que a
gente tinha como soca na nossa aqui e me
Diga exatamente então para o gabinete do
governador que nos disponibilizar se
quadros do estado da área da história da
antropologia nutrição que a gente
pudesse formar uma equipe de pesquisa
porque a pergunta que eu me seja o
seguinte o que eu sei da culinária do
Rio Grande do Sul e o que se sabe da
culinária Grande do Sul bem pensei Então
vamos procurar as nossas universidades
porque a gente está num crescente de
curso de gastronomia do Sul hoje nós
temos 17 instituições de ensino que se
ocupam do ensino da Gastronomia
dicas universidades eram todas muito
ainda jovens e portanto quase nenhuma
pesquisa na área de gastronomia e muito
menos pesquisa na área do regional né
dos nossos fazeres e saberes
tradicionais do Estado do Rio Grande do
Sul ainda tínhamos muito uma referência
da culinária italiana francesa né como
carro-chefe do ensino da gasolina Tá
bom mas começamos um diálogo com as
Universidades e paralela isso começamos
então a andar pelo Rio Grande do Sul na
terceira cidade que eu fui com essa
equipe que Montamos no palácio que eram
duas historiadoras alguns Estagiários e
sim de diferente as áreas
chegamos a duas conclusões
eu acho que foi a terceira viagem
primeiro é
e onde estão essas memórias né a gente
começou a se dar conta porque a gente
muito ligava para cidades e perguntava
tem um Historiador que se ocupa de
estudar alguma coisa de alimentação tem
um antigo estabelecimento tem um
produtor reconhecido na cidade em cima e
a gente começou a pensar assim não essas
memórias estão nas pessoas de mais idade
né E aí que estão essas memórias E aí
que a gente pode ter acesso a essas
memórias e a verdadeira história da
Gastronomia do estado e da comida do
nosso Estado ainda estão nas suas
memórias vivas dessas pessoas e a gente
começou então teve a ideia de procurar e
acessar os grupos de terceira idade do
Estado Rio Grande do Sul que cada cidade
tem inúmeros grupos de terceira idade
organizados seja pela Secretaria de
Assistência seja pelo Sesc enfim várias
instituições se ocupam na tem esses
grupos organizados então a gente Decidiu
não agora então nós os nossos contatos
estão secretários de assistência a
cessar os grupos de terceira idade e
conhecer começar até a sua experiência e
o segundo são os produtores onde é que
eles estão principalmente na Emater de
cada cidade de cada município tem esse
contato e relacionado todo esse grupo de
produtos e todos estabelecemos com os
nossos dois focos de pesquisa seria os
grupos de terceira idade e os produtores
ligados em matéria de cada município e
foi aí que nós começamos Então esse
trabalho dia segunda constatação também
eu acho que na terceira quarta cidade
foi a seguinte Gente o que nós estamos
fazendo aqui não é para subsidiar o
trabalho da cozinha do Palácio por aqui
na verdade nós estamos construindo uma
política pública que é muito mais Ampla
já cozinha do Palácio Piratini e uma
política que tem muito muito a ser feito
no estado e uma importância e urgência
fundamental do ser realizado e eu digo
uma urgência fundamental porque a gente
de cada narrativa de pessoa que a gente
de pessoas a rádio que a gente começou a
entrevistar a gente começou a se dar
conta da urgência de se registros efeito
que sob pena de ser
então nós voltamos
conversamos com o governador equipe e
propusemos o seguinte se ele nos
autorizavam começar a construir um texto
base para a criação Então por decreto
dele de um grupo de trabalho de pesquisa
em torno da cidade do Rio Grande do Sul
dos produtos Grande do Sul teve onze de
dezembro de2011 nós então lá no palácio
com muitos produtores já pesquisadores
de Universidade Principalmente as
Universidades nós iniciamos esse grupo
de trabalho com 25 entidades da área de
alimentos e bebidas e e acho que o
importante disso dessa experiência aqui
pela primeira vez a gente começava a
pensar numa política pública onde a
gastronomia estava no centro de uma
política pública sete secretarias de
estado foram designados para participar
desse grupo e
pela primeira vez da Secretaria de
Cultura agricultura turismo meio
ambiente educação e saúde sentavam uma
mesma mesa sobre o tema da Gastronomia
esse trabalho então é um trabalho muito
importante assim para nós durou quatro
anos esse trabalho na finalizamos o
trabalho então com 64 entidades da área
de alimentos e bebidas
e
essa é a saída Então nossa para os
grupos de terceira idade passava pelo
seguinte a gente ligava para o interior
o grupo às vezes 50 principalmente
mulheres né
Eu até mais às vezes Como lembro embaixo
já é assim quase 70 80 pessoas dali a
gente fazia um grande trabalho de
sensibilização falava que nós estávamos
querendo fazer Fazemos uma escuta grande
coletiva e desse grande grupo nós
estávamos Então cinco seis sete
entrevistas que a gente fazia
pormenorizada depois desse trabalho do
grande grupo E aí era esse registro que
eu digo sempre não é um registro de
receitas porque a nossa música Não Era
por receita nós queríamos entender o
contexto daquela comida como Aquela
comida surgiu naquela comunidade as
transformações que ela surgiu e ela
passou ao longo do tempo os produtos
envolvidos os produtos substitui e era
isso que nós queríamos entender e ao
mesmo tempo com alguém já falou aqui nos
interessava também aquelas histórias de
vidas que estavam complicadas com essa
comida era isso que nos interessavam
ao longo de quatro anos a gente
conseguiu fazer o registro de nós temos
registro 1600 entrevistas ao longo de
quatro anos lá pelas tantas como
Trabalho Público todo mundo sabe que
isso sofre sempre o processo infeliz da
interrupção a gente propôs então que a
fundação de pesquisa do Estado abrisse o
edital público e pela primeira vez no
Brasil a gente abriu o edital público
para pesquisar a cultura alimentar no
estado quatro grandes grupos
Universidade Então se envolveram também
junto com conosco paralelo esse trabalho
e é por isso então tem esse volume tão
grande de entrevistas e um total de 172
cidades do Estado ele estava
o presidente que a gente poderia pode
sofrer a crítica dizer que ele é um
trabalho muito ainda superficial pelo
pela quantidade né de municípios que a
gente tem estado mas a gente optou pela
amplitude do trabalho para a gente poder
ter um pouco desse olhar das diferenças
do estado é por isso que eu queria falar
aqui até eu chegar no palácio para tive
nós pegarmos o palácio era reconhecido
como alguém é o lugar onde se comia
churrasco O Carreteiro tá esses dois
pratos e o me lembro assim que eu acho
que no terceiro quarto cardápio que eu
fiz assim para um é gente eu já fui lá e
liguei para o submeter né porque tudo
muito difícil de serviço público para
aqui a ilha da pintada pudesse trazer né
o peixe na Taquara já para um evento no
palácio
Ah e assim nós estamos indo né Há
também um segundo terceiro evento já
chamamos os Caminhos Rurais de Porto
Alegre para fazer alguma coisa já com as
plantas alimentícias não-convencionais e
servimos um pão de curtida né lá no
terceiro quarto evento do Palácio E
assim a gente foi um pouco quebrando né
Essa Ideia de que o Rio Grande do Sul só
possa ser representado por dois pratos
emblemáticos e então esse esse nosso
trabalho por que que eu considero tão
importante esse trabalho de catalogação
desses saberes e fazeres tradicionais
Porque infelizmente nós vivemos num
momento onde a padronização da
alimentação é algo impressionante
nós vamos e comemos as mesmas coisas em
todos os lugares
nós e a Organização das famílias pelo
processo de alimentação fora do lar por
essa perda de referência da cozinha como
lugar de um desses fazer como lugar né a
cozinha como lugar de compartilhamento
de uma série de questões que nós estamos
perdendo nesse afastamento da cozinha
faz com que também a gente ser perca a
memória dos nossos pratos da nossa
cultura daquilo que a nossa daquilo e é
da nossa tradição
Então o dia que uma pesquisa dessa
natureza considera importante o que
talvez seja hoje na alimentação escolar
e a gente possa recuperar nesses
cardápios e a gente já tem uma lei no
Brasil felizmente na já designa que
trinta por cento tem que vir da
agricultura familiar Ou seja tem que vir
da produção local mas a gente tem que ir
junto com essa lei poder também
trabalhar questão da cultura alimentar
local na elaboração desses dados de uma
pesquisa dessa natureza é importante
porque ela pode fazer com que os
municípios cada vez mais ao tomarem
consciência de que eles estão tratando
alta carne da comida tão tratando de um
bem o que eles possam também criar
políticas públicas para a área da
alimentação escolar onde a gente possa
fazer com que as nossas crianças fazem a
comer aquilo que é da nossa tradição e
eu comer aquilo que ela nossa tradição
talvez elas consigam ainda incorporar
alguma coisa do dia nosso e tem uma
relação com a comida para nossa comida
uma relação de Cultura de pertencimento
de identidade e isso talvez fique ainda
na sua memória porque o que a gente tá
vendo é uma geração que vem sem nenhuma
memória sobre a comida da casa da mãe
sobre a comida da casa da vó e assim por
diante então
eu Pra finalizar eu queria dizer para
vocês todos que foi muita emoção fazer
todo esse trabalho O trabalho de não
tinha um ponto de referência a gente
começou
errando acertando
indo junto uma a todas um apoio Como eu
disse de muitas entidades o chefe de
cozinha os cozinheiros profissionais
foram os últimos a entrar nesse processo
e não foi nem uma exclusão a eles é
porque a gente pensava que a nossa
unidade maior era um com as
Universidades com quem se ocupava de
ensino da Gastronomia mas hoje a gente
tem alegria de dizer que mesmo a gente
tendo encerrado esse trabalho
institucional que a gente continua unido
cozinheiros produtores e entidades
diversidade estamos agora no momento de
construção do Instituto da Gastronomia
Regional para dar segmento esse trabalho
porque isso tem pesquisas urgente da
gente fazer principalmente ligar da
comida indígena e quilombola do Estado
do Rio Grande do Sul que quase nunca
foram estudadas estradas e várias outras
pesquisas que a gente precisa fazer eu
quero agradecer oportunidade isso aqui
talvez pela primeira vez falar no Rio
Grande do Sul de um tema como esse E aí
a todos que nessa caminhada de 4 anos
disseram que a gente tivesse hoje com
orgulho o maior acervo catalogado de
saberes e fazeres do Brasil registrados
então muito obrigado a
o quê